a good friend of mine which I'm thrilled
to be able to say and back here on the
Rich Eisen show from Sunday Night
Football on NBC I know Michaels how are
you out and great it's good to be with
you yesterday great to be with you today
and hopefully I'll see you down the line
in short order nice research it's so
good to see a schedule come out and
again you know it's being very
optimistic and you're on top of it you
don't know what's going to happen
tomorrow or next week or whenever and
you know right now not only did they
come out with the schedule but they came
out I think with the preseason schedule
as well because should we're on the
docket for a couple of games in August
so let's see what happens you know what
that is basically what I think the NFL
wanted to do let's just get out there
let's get it all out there and we'll
adjust once we do get it all out there
and that's why they did that with the
draft last week al is like because if
not then then when and teams can now
basically plan as best they can and then
adjust and and and you look at the
schedule and they you know this isn't
like dipping a toe in the pool you know
what I mean and figuring it out down the
line a real deal
raising of the banner in Kansas City
with deshaun Watson coming in and then
you come here to Los Angeles to open up
the new stadium with the Cowboys I mean
that is a what week that that's his real
deal as any schedule would start for you
and NBC you know is listening to you
talk about the history of the stadium
and you and I both know it because you
know living in LA but I go all the way
back to when the Rams played in the
Coliseum and they were the only team in
town and they decided they didn't want
to play in the Coliseum anymore the move
to Anaheim and that opened up the
Coliseum for the Raiders tonight had two
teams coming in and then you had both
teams leaving mm-hmm in 1994 Oakland
goes back to to their original digs Rams
go to st. Louis rich I'm thinking about
a couple of different things one of them
because a friend of ours Rd Hubbard the
great racetrack and for sorry if he died
last week I think at the age of 84 but
Rd Hubbard had made a deal with Al Davis
to build to build a Raider stadium at
Hollywood Park where the sophist
he was going to be now there was a big
sign up there a future home of the
Raiders that went away and then I don't
know if you remember this but al Davis
and only Al Davis could have pulled this
off pieces said getting sued he used to
do the shoeing you know just litigate
baby but he went to he went to the town
of Earl window which is nice but a
gravel pit with about 28 people and
somehow someway extracted a personal
check to him for ten million dollars ten
million dollars of the Irwindale budget
which I had no idea that had a thousand
dollars in it he got a non-refundable
ten million dollar check from a guy
named Xavier he had a Micheel who was
the city manager of Irwindale and I felt
so badly about it well you know you know
what hit the fan when everybody said
where in the world did that money come
from the Davis gave Hermosillo a job in
the Raiders front office I think in the
ticket department I mean you can't make
stuff up
you can't and then so they leave and now
you've got all kinds of possibilities
farmers feel remember that that of
course next to Staples Center right that
that went to that went away then you had
the thing in Carson with all the methane
gas underneath there and that was where
the Raiders in the Chargers are G we're
going to play and then Stan Kroenke
comes in and comes said rides in and
comes in to the rescue and it's only
costing 5.5 billion dollars it set up
but it's going to be great rich but
Jerry Jones is is a no-brainer first
guest for an owner to bring his team in
Oh
for that one Jerry Jerry knew I mean
look Jerry build the Taj Mahal of
stadiums I mean that stadium is right
now I think 13 years old 12 years old
it's still to me it's beautiful its
pristine Jerry only those things first
class top grade and you walk around that
stadium and I mean you it's one of those
you know the old cliche been eating off
the floor you can't they maintain it
perfectly and he knew in Stan he had a
guy who had the same kind of vision so
the only difference would be not the
only
Texas is a right-to-work state and
California is a union state so the
stands only spend at about five times
what Jerry did to build his Taj Mahal
and yeah and now he's coming here for
for week one around Sunday Night
Football and then I'm looking at some of
the other Sunday night games you got
Brady twice won in Las Vegas and then
one at home you've got the other week
one is on Fox with Brady coming out of
the gate at Brees but you've got Brees
at Brady and week nine that's just gonna
be dynamite I'll just dynamite well you
know what I look at that game in Vegas
and it's going to be exciting obviously
to go into Vegas and see what that's all
about but with Tampa Bay going in there
in week seven
remember back rich to the August January
February after the Patriots season is
over and what is Tom gonna do where is
he gonna wind up well he wind up with
the Chargers and I think a lot of people
thought that he was gonna wind up with
me with the Raiders he would go to Las
Vegas and I know I think I mentioned on
the telecast that we did yesterday rich
about I was in Vegas and late February
and they are very excited about the team
they were very excited about the draft
they were really excited the locals they
thought they had a real good chance to
get Tom Brady so they're going to get
Tom Brady but he's going to be in a
different uniform right on Sunday night
the 25th of October another Vegas game
is on the record 22nd right before
Thanksgiving Kansas City at the Raiders
so our two games in Las Vegas if you
will have Tom Brady and Patrick mahomes
and that's pretty cool
Irene you've got Ravens Patriots again
this time around though it's Ravens at
Patriots and then last year obviously
the Ravens just stomping the Patriots
was I guess a watershed moment in the
season last year for both teams I'm
wondering did you and and Chris pick up
anything when you chatted with Brady
last year about that Brady was out the
door because he has subsequently said
now that he is in Tampa telling your
friend oh you have appeared on the
Howard Stern Show Wow
telling your friend the king of all
media that that that he he knew he was
gone last summer is what he said did you
sense any of that when you chatted with
Brady prior to Sunday Night Football
games in New England with New England
last year first of all you are the king
of warm you run constantly forget about
our you know it got a lot of publicity
we talked about this with you and a
couple of other people in the past
couple of months so we did that game
which was the ninth or tenth week of the
season anyway the Patriots came into
Baltimore early in November on Sunday
night and they were eight no they were
undefeated halfway through the season
everybody was saying about you and the
schedule is easy and defense and yeah
the defense was great they were
averaging giving up Lexington I think
ten points per game and Brady was he was
doing okay but that's when Tom said and
he said it with a little bit of a smile
in our production meeting on the
unhappiest eight and Oh quarterback in
football and that's gotten a lot of play
out there but that's exactly what he
said he didn't say I'm the unhappiness
quarterback I'm happiest 8bo quarterback
of course how many eight no quarterbacks
were there at that particular time right
but anyway you got the point but still
like I said across the table and you
know we've covered I'm a lot in the
through the years I've known I know him
pretty well and I know how much Bob crap
loves him I mean craft talks about the
fact he's like another son and crap and
Brady have got along so famously that
even though there might have been
whatever it was and I'm not sure I don't
know what it was with he and Belichick
and it was anything I don't know maybe
bill just wanted to look to the future
maybe Tom just wanted a change nobody
seems to know I think it was a
confluence of events but I can't say
that I really saw nor did Chris at that
point that it was you know a possibility
yeah a scant possibility maybe but the
fact that he would walk out the door
shocking and in fact you know I was
trying to get the answer out of him by
by saying to Tom all right listen I'm
gonna I'm going to lay odds of 43,000 to
one
right now a dish table that you will
never wear another uniform any kind of
laughs and then one of our top research
guys Andy Friedland plunked down two
bucks so now I'm I'm on the hook for
eighty six thousand dollars and I never
want to see Andy again I bet you know
and it's interesting to our Michaels
here on the Rich Eisen show not one not
two but three Packers games on the
schedule week three dynamite game
Packers at Saints they latest iteration
of bears at Packers in week twelve and
then a Titans Packers game all the way
at the end that's a 3G situation right
there for you guys as we pop the
schedule up here and we had we had Favre
on this show to Wednesdays ago and he
said that the Jordan loved drafting will
definitely have the wheels turning
inside Rogers his head and you're gonna
watch that drama play out in year two
Matt Lafleur and and Aaron Rodgers and
what's going on right in front of your
very eyes with some pretty big games for
this team huh how do you how do you as
somebody who's watched the the young
Montana stuff the Favre Rodgers stuff
you've seen this play out before do you
do you see this another situation like
what we're assuming it is well well you
sure made news with a carve interview
that was that was something I heard it
that day and that was I thought that was
pretty interesting obviously and a lot
of people picked up on it you know I
look at the top quarterbacks through you
know all the years that I've I've done
this unit to Marino and Montana and you
know with Brady and and the Manning boys
and even Aaron Rodgers right now in his
mid thirties and everybody saying well
you know this is the kind of thing that
lights a fire under them and I'm
thinking of myself and go back to you
know Garoppolo souvenir crafted by doing
on a few years back I know these guys
they don't need a fire lit under them
these guys are all out all the time and
there's all knowing these guys there's
not one of them that I knew was it all
out no matter what was going on so when
people say oh boy this will really good
Aaron crazy or
or he'll be a better quarterback because
she's got this guy behind him I don't
buy that I don't buy that Aaron Rodgers
has so much pride and and is so
intelligent and gets everything that I
don't see Aaron Rodgers because Jordan
love is there on the bench playing any
better than he would had you know you
had anybody else behind him on the bench
like you know an older quarterback a guy
that was gonna take his place someday
right so I I'm not one that buys into
the fact that you've got to motivate
these guys who are super motivated to
begin with have great pride in what they
do and I just some of a mind to expect
them to play exactly the way they would
play if none of this was happening on
the side yeah and last year I mean you
called the Packers 49ers game that was
another watershed moment I would say
certainly what that was when the Niners
spanked and the Packers coming off of a
bye week and that that's what I think
they kind of grabbed the okay there for
real montreux and ran with it all the
way through to beating the Packers in
the NFC Championship game and those were
the last two Packers losses of their
entire season you got the Niners three
times out right now as it's currently
slated how good do you think this team
is based on everything that you've
already seen moving around chess pieces
from NFC teams from a free agency draft
of the card a very very good rich
because and we talked about it being a
49ers three times last year it turned
out in a two and flex and then we had
them in the playoffs against Minnesota
and I keep going back and I repeated it
every time we had the 49ers with John
Lynch and Kyle Shanahan said the first
thing they wanted to do is build a Super
Bowl defensive line and when you look at
how they've constructed that team and if
you want to go back to that Green Bay
regular season game and Levi's Stadium
the 49ers were able to blow him out
early because of the pressure that was
put on by the defensive line yet the
Rodgers fumble and and then you know the
roof
early so you've got that defense which
is terrific and they played very well of
course in the Super Bowl up until the
last six and a half or seven minutes of
the game so I look at them defensively
and I think they're very strong I think
Garoppolo is a really good quarterback I
mean people are trying to pick him apart
right now he's whatever you know they
want to say okay got it he's got some
good receivers you got the running backs
really came through they had a whole
bunch room last year I like the way
Shanahan and and Lynch
have constructed this team I think
they're very clear-eyed I think they
they see exactly what they need to do to
make this team a contending team and
they clearly are mean they're back it's
like the you know the glory days are
back they had two glorious decades then
the 2000 decade wasn't particularly good
until Harbaugh got there and then they
were good again and then they fell off
the end of the earth again another back
so I think the the 49ers looked to me
like they were team that's poised for a
good long run here well last night in
that conversation that I had with you
and Joe Buck who's joining us in about
seven minutes time and Jim Nantz who's
joining us at the very end of the hour
in that conversation we had live on NFL
Network last night I think we had our
first flex of the season with Jim Nance
talking about the mahomes at brady game
and that's the game that everybody wants
on the screen i think he was flexing
right there al and i think i think he I
think he put the preemptory chip for CBS
on that game right away there I think
you have to come through Nance to go get
that game on NBC this fall I don't know
you know when it comes to the league
making up the schedule that and $0.20
will get you nothing you know I mean all
these years you know living out on the
west coast you know I enjoy when on the
schedule comes out and I see a few West
Coast games and I'm looking at this
schedule right I sneak up on it one by
one and I know we're like we have to
open the Kansas City but I'm sneaking up
on it yesterday when they came out that
goes open a game at LA good I'm in bed
that night at home there guys Seattle
bears at night - flying back home San
Fran and week four great because we have
a week five were specific I'm going wait
a second what happened here I mean I
mean my 35th year of doing it in 34
years I think I've had eight games in
the Pacific time zone now I've got like
11 in one year so I am I am worshipping
at the shrine of Howard Katz yeah it's
not to say you're mentioning the
executive who's atop the scheduling
flowchart you've known how you
you've known Howard since blood since
like some sort of motocross day that you
did Wide World of Sports back in the 70s
with Bruce Jenner pretty much Denison
like that in fact my father passed away
in 83 of my father and Mark McCormick
started Transworld international okay
Twi which is a part of IMG and my father
and McCormick ran it and Howard were
from my dad over 40 years ago so we go
all the way back I mean way way way way
back and then Howard you know we're
living out in California now he lives
just outside of Philadelphia but oh yeah
we go we go far far back and who would
have ever thought that someday you know
I have to call Howard and say man this
is this is the bait the best I can I can
do this whole schedule on a Greyhound
bus I love it before I let you go out
give me good give me a good wide world
of sports story what's the craziest
thing you did from Wide World of Sports
motorcycles on ice enzo west germany
1977 i get on the block i would do
anything they wanted me to do the scene
set by riding down the strip of ice in
front of like 15,000 wild and woolly
germans who've been drinking schnapps
all afternoon and i had never been on a
motorcycle in my life I'd barely been on
a Schwinn
I needed training wheels but I'm ready
to do this they put me in the leathers
of a guy who's like five six and 145
pounds from Russia at that point I'm
probably 510 180 and I can't breathe
and now I don't know how to work the the
motor so I don't know what to do and it
was a clutch sure thing whatever I don't
know what dials to turn was doing with
my feet and all I know is at one point I
started to rev it and had somebody not
grabbed the clutch
I would have been launched along with
Sawyer's oh I don't there with very good
garbage space somewhere we survived we
made it and you know when you're when
you're the rookie and you're the kid
you'll do anything and then all of a
sudden you get a little older and you go
get out of town class yes so there was
no agony of defeat basically it would
have been a memorial service that is I
Love You Man best to Linda we'll chat
soon okay buddy thanks to Colette Sal
Michaels hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here